And my weight's keep changing.
Helps me making decisions.
I got a predicted hello world,
it Suraj and in this video I'll teach
you how backpropagation the most popular
optimization algorithms in machine
learning works. Machine learning,
deep learning, modern artificial
intelligence is in general,
centered around a topic called
it mathematical optimization.
Optimization is a distinct branch of
applied math that's useful in a ton of
different industries like manufacturing,
transportation and economics.
Optimization comes from the same
root as optimal, which means best.
When you optimize something,
you are making it the best and the
word best varies based on the context.
If you're a basketball player,
you might want to maximize your jump
and minimize your fouls to be like Mike,
the concept of both maximizing
and minimizing or different
types of optimization
problems. A basic optimization
problem consists of three core ideas.
First, a function, let's call it f of x.
We want to maximize or minimize
the output of this function.
That's our goal or objective,
so let's call it an objective function.
Secondly, we can't control the
output, but we can control the inputs.
These are our variables. That could be
one or many depending on the use case.
Lastly, there are usually some kind
of constraints on our objective.
These places have limits on how big
or small some variables can get.
In the case of our basketball player,
if he's main goal is to maximize
his number of free throws,
that becomes his objective function.
He can choose to spend his time doing
any number of things like running or jump
exercises to help achieve that goal.
These are variables and there are certain
limits to the total amount of training
time he has. For example, he
can't run for more than say,
30 minutes each day due
to schedule conflicts.
Aka Fortnite is too much fun.
These are constraints.
There are a lot of variations
to this scenario. We could have,
there could theoretically
be no constraints,
which would mean this would
be an unlimited problem.
It could have just one variable or many.
These variables could be discreet,
having only integer values,
or they could be continuous
taking on any value.
The problem could be static or
unchanging over time or dynamic,
meaning continual adjustments
could be made as changes occur.
It could be deterministic,
meaning specific inputs cause specific
outputs or stochastic meaning there is
randomness to the outputs.
So despite all of these
possible variations,
the practice of framing this as an
optimization problem helps us solve it.
Alternatively,
we could just be guessing and checking
different inputs for our problem,
but never fully knowing what the
ideal or optimal inputs should be.
Optimization is a better solution
than this guess and check strategy.
So how does all of this
relates to machine learning?
Machine learning is the practice of
building mathematical models that we'll
learn from datasets to make predictions.
There are so many different ways
we can describe this process.
One way is to say that it consists
of three parts. Representation,
evaluation and optimization.
Let's say we have a Dataset for a list
of NFL teams with the number of wins in a
given season and the average points
per game for each of them does.
The more points a team averages in a
game lead to more wins in a season.
Can we predict how many games a team
will win based on a number of points,
a team averages in a game?
We can use machine learning to find out.
My dear Watson representation is the
space of models we could use for some
dataset.
There are so many different machine
learning models that we could use a three
layer feed forward neural network,
a support vector machine,
a decision tree,
but let's start with something simple.
A linear regression model.
It's aligned that intersects as
many data points as possible.
Then using that line we can make
a prediction about any team.
We can by hand draw out
this line ourselves,
but we can't know for sure that it's
intersecting as many data points as it can
with our human judgment.
This process of trying to judge its
performance is called evaluation.
In machine learning,
this is usually called the error function.
There is a certain possibility space
of parameter values for our model and
depending on what those parameters are,
the error will change.
If we were to graph out
all of those possibilities,
assuming that there are only
two possible parameters,
we get a three d plane of possibility
of the many popular error functions.
Let's try a simple one
called mean squared error.
We essentially calculate the difference
between the models output and the actual
data point. Our graph, we'll
have hills and valleys.
We are evaluating for the height of this
landscape and the lowest area is the
most optimal because that's the
point where the error is smallest.
You'll then also give us the optimal
parameter values for our model to achieve
that error.
The process of searching this space of
our represented model to obtain a better
valuation is called optimization.
We have to traverse the landscape to
find the promised land of ideal parameter
values for our model optimization is the
strategy of getting to where we want to
go. We can use gradient
descent year to optimize.
We'll initialize our parameters
or weights with random values.
Then calculate the error using our
error function. This is a single number.
Now we're going to use that error value
to compute the partial derivative.
With respect to both of our parameter
values, we can call this the gradient.
Alright, let's take a
step back. Unintended.
The derivative is a term from calculus,
the study of change.
It measures the steepness of a graph
of a function at some particular point.
On that graph,
we can think of the derivative as a slope.
That's the ratio of change in the value
of the function to the change in a
variable.
It's represented by this little squiggly
character and we want to change both of
our parameter values,
so will compute the partial derivative
of each meaning we derive one and treat
the other as a constant respectively.
We do that for both of them
and this gives us the gradient.
The gradient is a multivariable
generation of the derivative.
While a derivative can be defined on
functions of a single variable for
functions of several variables,
the gradient takes its place.
We can use it to update both of
our parameter values ever slow,
slightly in a certain direction on
this plane that will move closer to the
smallest possible error and we do
this over and over and over again.
Over time, the parameters
converging to their optimal values.
It's like letting a ball roll
down into the bottom of a bowl.
The gradient is a compass that helps
us descend down the valley to where the
error is.
Smallest gradient descent can be used in
many different machine learning models,
but it's most popularly
used in neural networks.
In the context of neural networks.
Grading dissent is just
renamed backpropagation
and your whole network is a
function just like our linear
regression model is a function.
It's a series of matrix operations that
are applied to some input data that
results in an output.
When we compute the error and use it
to compute the partial derivative with
respect to its parameters,
we get the gradient data is propagated
forward through the computation graph of
operations.
An error is computed and
propagated backwards by
computing gradients recursively
for every set of layers in the network.
So while the models all use different
mathematical operations to compute
predictions,
the optimization strategy of gradient
descent remains the same depending on how
big our Dataset is,
we can choose to run grading dissent
in batches and mini batches or in a
stochastic way.
Batch descent is when we compute the
error of all the training samples at once,
every iteration of training.
This can take a long time to compute for
big data sets of though so many batch
gradient descent.
Let's a split our training data into
many batches that can be processed
individually.
Stochastic gradient descent
is when we perform an update.
Every single training observation,
the size of our batch leads to
the fastest learning process.
Depending on the size of our dataset.
There've been a lot of variations to
gradient descent that have been used over
the years.
Sometimes the gradient gets stuck in
a local minimum and doesn't reach the
global minimum.
Momentum is a technique that uses the
moving average gradient instead of the
immediate gradient at each time step.
To preserve the momentum has
we approach smaller valleys.
This can slow the convergence process,
but a fixed to this is to use rms prop
which will adaptively scale the learning
rate.
A combination of both ideas is called
Adam or adaptive moment estimation.
Adam is currently the most
popular iteration of gradient
descent and you'll see
it a lot in code basis. I know
that was a lot, but stay with me.
Three things to remember from this video.
Mathematical optimization is a way of
framing a problem in order to maximize or
minimize some goal or objective.
Machine learning uses optimization to
find the optimal parameter values for a
model to make the best
predictions and gradient descent.
Also called backpropagation when applied
to neural networks is the most popular
optimization strategy.
What's my next topic? Using machine
learning, you could probably predict it.
Subscribe for more educational
videos about Ai, and for now,
I've got a guest lecturer at Ucla,
so thanks for watching.